okay thank you for the introduction and
thank you all for stay until this very
last talk so I would do that at the end
of the talk I just wanted to wake you up
so I mean that might be an explanation I
just wanted to drag attention to the
talk so the stock will be focusing on
simple things little things and slow
things and whether it is supposed to
mean that I be studying parameterize
complexity and exponential time
complexity in this talk let me just
explain a bit what these three words are
supposed to mean so simple means that we
want to count perfect matchings in
graphs that have a certain simple
structure little is supposed to mean
that we shook on small things that
appear in something large like some
small sub graphs appearing in a huge
graph then finally slow would mean I
were able to find tight condition lower
bounds on the running times for such
problems and yeah that's before diving
into that let me just briefly recap
what's going on in classical counting so
in classical counting complexity we are
given counting problems like this one
here sharpy where the input is some
object X and the output that you're
interested in is the number of some
structures that appear in X so example
stories could be count we set where the
input is a formula Phi in three CNF and
you want to count the satisfying
assignments that appear in Phi another
one could be con sub where you're given
a pattern graph H and host graph G and
you're interested in counting H copies
ng not so not necessarily in use in this
setting and then we also have counting
perfect matchings where you're given a
graph and you want to output the number
of perfect matching set of PNG
and then finally we're counting a vertex
covers we are given a graph g until
number k and you're interested in the
number of Khaybar Tex covers that appear
in G so these are all classical counting
problems and in classical County
complexity what we usually get is a
dichotomy and two and two problems that
are polynomial-time solvable l problems
that are Sharpie heart under two
introductions so let me just briefly
record what that means problem is
Sharpie heart if you can get a
polynomial time algorithm for counting
three set when you're given an Oracle
for sharp be ok and under this classical
notion we have of course that accounting
3 set is Sharpie heart but also counting
subgraphs a Sharpie hard for instance
because it subsumes counting cake leaks
as a special case but we know even that
deciding whether rock contains okay
clicks NP complete and affect this
reductionist parsimonious so this
problems also Sharpie hard exactly the
same applies to counting k vertex covers
but more interestingly accounting
perfect matchings as hard by a non
parsimonious reduction and this was this
initial result by valiant so okay as
we've seen in this slide there are four
problems all of them a sharpie heart and
like as a conclusion from the talks that
we had previously in this in this
workshop I guess it's safe to say that
most interesting counting problems that
you can study a Sharpie heart so there
is a need to move on of course people
have moved on in the past already so one
example might be we can consider
restricted import grubs so for instance
counting perfect matchings is
polynomial-time solvable in planar
graphs by this wonderful fkd methods the
genie introduced in one of the first
talks we also have approximate counting
of course so if you just want to compute
the number of perfect matchings in the
bipartite graph with some error then you
can get an F price for this problem and
then maybe a slightly weird a relaxation
would be will not account modular fix
prime so for instance counting perfect
matchings modulo 2 is something that we
can do
no time just by reducing to the
determinant so in fact determinant and
permanent are the same modulo 2 but then
more recent relaxation that I think has
not been mentioned so far here would be
a countenance of exponential time so for
most of the counting problems that that
we've seen earlier like the best known
algorithms are actually exponential so
they run in time let's say 2 to the n
when n is the number of vertices in your
graph and there are actually cases where
we have Sharpie heart problems but we
can get some exponential algorithms and
this is of course awesome because where
this might mean for instance that we can
now drive up the maximum instant size
that would be still feasible on a
computer from let's say 20 to 400 if
lack in this case we get a square root
and in the exponent so for instance
counting matchings which are not
necessarily perfect is a Sharpie hard
problem as opposed to counting perfect
matchings in planar graphs okay so
counting matchings in a planar graph and
although it's Sharpie heart can be
solved in this sub exponential time then
finally we have this kind of mysterious
relaxation of parameterize counting that
I'd be focusing on in this talk and in
fact this top would be a combination of
these three relaxations so we will
consider combinations of applying these
realizations to counting problems and
seeing whether this makes our problem
any easier so let me start first by this
parameterize counting business so the
objects in study and parameterize
counting are just parameterize counting
problems so that's just a normal
counting problem where you get an input
and you're interested in some number of
structures in your input but here
additionally we have this parameter so
the parameter is just a function that
maps from inputs to natural numbers and
it assigns a value couple of X to each
input such that this parameter this
value here and kind of measures the
complexity of your input graph in a way
that that is additional to the mere
input length that you would get in
classical counting so examples for such
parameterize
mounting problems can be well let's
reconsider this problem of counting k
vertex covers and you can take the
number of khaybar text covers in your
graph as as a quantity that you want to
compute and just impose this parameter K
so from the input which is a graph G and
a number K you just extract this number
K and pick that as a parameter another
problem could be when you take counting
perfect matchings and parameterize by
the maximum degree of your graph or you
take counting cake leaks or counting
case cyclists in a graph and again
parametrized by the size of the of the
structure that you're interested in and
you can observe that these three
problems that are shown yellow here can
all be solved the time n to the K plus
some constant so for each fixed K we get
a polynomial time algorithm for these
problems and just by brute force so here
for instance you could just enumerate
okay vertex subsets of your graph and
check whether it's a vertex cover and
the same works of course for K clicks
and K cyclists but here it for this
problem the situation is a bit different
and this problem is sharply hard even if
your maximum degree is bounded by three
so in a certain way this is a
parametrized problem that we do not want
to study in our theory because well it's
already Sharpie hard for a fixed charge
of the perimeter in a particular what
we're going to do with these yellow
problems cannot be applied to them
namely what we're going to do with these
things is we try to drag out this cave
from the exponent and put it in front of
n such as it appears no longer in a
function together with them let me make
this a bit more explicit so like this
central notion of parameterize
complexity is this notion of fixed
parameter tractability so a problem
would be fpt or fixed parameter
tractable if you can solve it in time f
of the parameter on x times input length
to some constant so you have some
function which may depend arbitrarily on
k or kappa your parameter but then you
have a polynomial in the input length so
one typical example for such a running
time would be where for this counting
vertex cover problem we can get an FPT
algorithm
that actually runs in time 2 to the K
times n so we managed to take out this K
from the exponent of n and put it in
front of n but at the expense of having
it now as an exponential and of course
we do need something super polynomial
here because otherwise you would have
soft an np-complete or a Sharpie
complete problem in polynomial time okay
and now the question is whether can we
do this for all of these problems that
have like this n to the K running times
and like the we want to study we want to
study whether such fpt algorithms can
also be found let's say four counting k
clicks or counting k cycles and to do
this we need a suitable complexity
theory and this is where parameterize
counting complexity sets in so in
parameterize counting complexity we have
a notion that is very parallel to the
classical Sharpie hardness which will
just be w one hardness or shop w one
hardness for counting so what does that
mean we just pick a lazy definition of
this of this notion because it's useful
for our purposes and there's also a
machine based characterization that but
let's ignore this for now for sake of
simplicity the problem sharp be with
your parameter kappa its sharp w one
heart if there is a duction from
counting cake leaks to the problem
sharpie and and this this reduction is
supposed to be a fixed parameter
tractable touring reduction so it means
that we have an algorithm for counting
cake leaks when given an Oracle for this
counting problem Sharpie this algorithm
is supposed to run an FPT time according
to the parameter K of K clicks and
additionally whenever this orchid issues
a query why then the parameter of that
query will be bounded by some computable
function and K so if you have these two
restrictions on your algorithm then
actually turns out that well if the
sharp B problem were contained an FPT
then counting k clicks would be as well
but people in complexity believe so it's
a standard assumption
parameterize complexity that accounting
techniques or deciding techniques cannot
be solved an equity time so applying
this theory we can now say trivially
that's counting k clicks a sharp w1
heart and but more interestingly
counting case like this chapter we want
heart as well and this is interesting
because the decision version of this
problem is fpt so you can decide in FP t
time by a technique called color coding
for instance that whether you're given
graph G contains a que cycle and again
the running time is something like 2 to
the K times some polynomial in n so this
in a certain way is like valiance
initial result that there are easy
decision problems which are hard to
count and this is essentially an analog
on of that for the primer traced word we
have a easy decision problem but it's
counting version is hard okay and
generally what we'll be doing in this
talk is so the general framework that
that we introduced so far of fpt nice
and sharp w1 hardness will allow us to
to do the following thing so we will
generally take Sharpie complete problems
where well we want to count something we
impose some interesting parameter on
that problem or maybe the parameter
turns out to be not that interesting as
all at all and then then we just do the
usual game like in in classical
complexity is attractable or not just
that like the notion of tractability
here is fpt or shell w1 heart so can we
solve our problem in some running time F
of K times polynomial in the input
length or do we actually need a running
time which looks like input length to
some function of K or in other words so
in both cases these problems always in
polynomial time for any fixed K there of
course also let's say here there could
be other problems that are sharply hard
even for fixed parameter choices but we
will ignore them here all of these
things are in polynomial time for fixed
K and the question is whether are they
actually in putting on the time for
fixed K with an expo
that depends no longer okay okay and one
first example where where this theory of
fpt where's the shop w one heart can be
applied very interestingly and gives us
some rich results is in the setting
where we want to count little things so
we want to count small things that
appear in something large and in
particular we'll be focusing on counting
sub graphs where we have a small sub
graph that appears in a huge graph so
again we have some pattern graph H which
is a graph on K vertices and we have a
host graph G which has n vertices and we
consider a G to be huge but it should be
very small and then we're interested in
counting sub graphs of this graph G that
are isomorphic to H and in the setting
that will be interested in these sub
graphs will be not necessarily induced
so first observation is of course that
you can always solve this problem in
time n to the K plus some constant times
some function of K because you can
essentially just guess k vertices in
your host graph and which amounts to
this n to the K and then once you
guessed k vertices in here you just
count how many ways there are to embed H
as a sub graph into these cable disease
but for special classes of graphs
actually there are much faster
algorithms so for instance if this graph
H work a clique which is our initial
chapter one hard problem then you can
actually solve this problem in time n to
the Omega K over three where Omega is
the exponent of matrix multiplication
which is certainly less than three so we
get an algorithm that is faster than
this year and there are other classes on
which you can do even faster so one
example might be that of counting case
cycles so if you want to count k circus
in a graph then you can do this in time
n to the 0.46 times K and in fact this
was a sort of recent breakthrough
because people believe that n to the K
halves would possibly be an optimal
running time
be achieved by a technique called meet
in the middle and but this was proper
babe your account and others but so far
all of these things do have these sharp
w1 style running times and what we are
more interested in is let's say a class
that would actually be fpt and actually
there is one but it's quite simple so
for instance if you want to count k
stars in a graph then you can do that in
linear time there is not even a
dependence on K anymore so a que star is
just well some vertex with K race on it
and to count that you would just do this
sum of all vertices in your graph so for
all vertex for every vertex in the graph
you just take this binomial coefficient
which has a degree of the vertex over K
because once you guessed the center of
your star does they're just there are
these many ways of distributing the race
among among the neighborhood of the
stuff and more generally we can now ask
this question and let's say we fix some
plus C and we restrict our pattern graph
to be to be coming from that class c and
for which classes see come he gets an
FPT running time rather than just an n
to the o of K running time which would
be guaranteed by this year so this is a
very natural question in parameterize
complexity i would say because of the
deciding whether graph contains a sub
graph is natural and then since counting
is natural counting sub graphs in a
graph is also natural and it's kind of
it's kind of natural also to
parameterize by K because there are
often situations where we have a tiny
pattern which is supposed to appear in a
huge graphic this could be some small
protein interaction pattern that appears
in some huge protein database I have no
idea what I'm talking about so yeah one
of the success stories so to say of this
parameter is counting business so far is
that if we define this form a problem
sharp subsea for recursively enumerable
draft classes see where you given us
import a pattern from your class see
DeGraff g and your parameterize by the
size of the pattern and and you
interested in accounting edge copies in
G then there is a sweeping dichotomy for
this problem according to FB t or shop w
1 so this dichotomy runs along the
maximum matching number that you can
find in in this class c so if your graph
has only matchings of bounded size so
there is some fixed constant that bounds
all the matchings in your class then
actually there is a polynomial time
algorithm for this problem so it's not
even fpt it's even polynomial time and
examples for such classes could be the
class of stars or generally graphs that
have a vertex cover of size 0 of 1 so I
constantly many vertices that see all
the edges and on the other hand if you
if your class has unbounded matchings
then the problem is sharp w1 heart so
this means in particular like a minimal
class that would fall into this into
this side of the dichotomy would of
course be the class of matchings so this
sharp w1 hardness of counting k
matchings was shown in for paper so far
and i think by now this last one could
actually have achieved a certain state
of readability and the first proof was
quite a mess and then successively
things became easier and then by
reducing from this from this bottleneck
problem for for the hard case of the
dichotomy we can get hardness for all
other kinds of problems as well so for
instance we can also reprove these
initial Arkansas results for counting k
parts accounting k cycles are generally
the stack automated hold for any class c
and like it could be that so far that so
far i couldn't convince you that
parameterize complexity is is an
interesting relaxation to study but i
think this picture here will give you a
reason to study parameterize complexity
even if you're not interested in
parameterize complexity because this
dichotomy tells you exactly when the
scope mounting sub graph problem is in
polynomial time and the thing that you
have to assume for this is that FB t is
not equal
w one so you might wonder now we're
couldn't we just proved this in a
classical setting it turns out that
they're actually Sharpie into immediate
cases so so if you were striving for
that cotton into polynomial time or
sharpy complete then this would not be
possible however adopting this stronger
assumption you can actually get a
sweeping dichotomy and this is not a
singular case in in in parameter s
complexity there are actually a lot of
problems of similar flavor where you fix
some pattern class c and you're
interested in counting or finding
structures from the class c so for
instance for accounting software as i
said already this property that makes
your problem polynomial time is having
bounded matching so matchings of
constant size otherwise it's sharp w1
heart but you also get something similar
for finite classes so if you if you're
interested in counting or finding
induced subgraphs and then you're in
polynomial time if your class is finite
otherwise you're sharp w1 heart if
you're interested in counting or finding
homomorphisms so here we consider the
left side to be fixed so the graph from
which we want to map which is kind of
the non-standard setting and then a
parameter called the tree with we make
your problem polynomial time otherwise
it's sharp w1 hard compare sharp i'll be
one heart and the same applies also to a
variant of counting sub graphs which is
called counting card offers up cross
where your graph has vertex colors and
you're interested in counting sub graphs
that are colorful and isomorphic to a
given pattern again here tree with its
is the criterion that makes it tractable
and in fact for all of these problems
you can you can define NP or you can
actually see that their MP or sharp the
intermediate cases so these are all
their companies that you couldn't get by
just looking at polynomial time or
sharpy completeness
okay so so far what we were to interview
so far is a framework for taking sharp
you complete problems imposing a
parameter and studying if they become
fpt or shop w one heart what we're going
to do now is actually like drive this
thing up a bit and we're interested
actually now in finding tight upper and
lower bounds for these functions F of K
so here we need to assume stronger
things of course then just fbt not being
equal to shop w one but if we do that
there are actually a lot of problems for
which you can get really tight like we
can tightly say which function f is
supposed to appear here so this brings
us to the slow things and part of the
talk where we want to find conditioner
conditional lower bounds on the running
time is needed to solve counting
problems so to do this we use the so
called exponential time hypothesis or
sharpy th which was introduced by in her
bleep a yacht so and others and later
adapted to do the counting setting by
dell and others and essentially Sharpie
th just states that if you want to count
satisfying assignments to a three CNF on
n variables then you cannot do that in
sub exponential time so not in time to
to the little oven and you might believe
this statement or not but in any in any
case and if you were able to refute it
then you would get a major breakthrough
so I guess it's it's well motivated to
to I guess it's well motivated to to try
to refute this and to build a complexity
theory is starting from Sharpie th that
might eventually be able to refute it
and or in just me that it is true then
then you immediately get your tight
lower bounds and there's something that
you believe which is probably even nicer
and which is how usually people proceed
in this area so first consequence of
sharp eth which is extremely useful is
the fact that by something that is
called the specification lemma we can
actually make a we can actually have a
consequence of sharp eth which is that
this problem sharp three set on n
variables cannot be solved in sub
exponential time even if your formula
has just often many clauses so in other
words even linear instances even
instances there are sparse that have a
linear number of clauses are already
hard and this is very important because
if you have this statement you can now
use classical reductions that were used
in NP hardness to get tight lower bounds
on a Sharpie th so as an example by just
taking the standard production for the
NP completeness of of finding three
colorings or but in our case for the
standards parsimonious reduction for
counting three colorings we can show
that counting three colorings on graphs
that have T vertices and that's a
problem that cannot be solved in time to
wot so why is that where I just have a
look at how this reduction proceeds so
if we take a formula Phi for which you
want to count satisfying assignments and
this formula has n variables and often
clauses then the reduction that we get
will essentially be roughly something
like this we have like n variable
gadgets & M like off and claws gadgets
each of these gadgets have some constant
size so we get a graph G which has some
number T of both n vertices and counting
three colorings in here is the
equivalent accounting satisfying
standards here so of course if you then
had a sub exponential time I wasn't for
counting three colorings here you would
get a sub exponential time algorithm
four counting satisfying assignments
here which would then refute this and
then we future p th and like this
approach would not work if you did not
have the specification because then we
could not assume that we have just often
clauses like for instance our three CNF
formula might have something like n cube
for clauses and then the reduction image
here would have cubic size so you cannot
get this tight implication anymore but
another very nice implication that
actually can be soft that actually can
be shown by reduction from this three
coloring problem is that you cannot
count k clicks in time n to the little o
of K and assuming Sharpie th so this
means in particular that ETH implies
that counting k clicks is not fpt so if
you if you kind of found this notion of
fpt where's the shrub w1 hearts weird
are not interesting that you are more
comfortable with ETH then where this
reduction you can also feel more
comfortable chopped w1 hardness it gives
an alternative way of proving that the
things are not in a few teen and again
this is a stronger so in particularly
shows the ETH or something stronger but
possibly not strictly stronger than the
FBT not being able to share w one okay
so this would be like the part where I
introduce the
yes so for instance if you now had a
reduction from counting k clicks to some
other problem that increases your
parameter only by some constant
multiplicatively then then the same
lower bound would apply so for instance
if you reduce from counting k clicks to
counting 3 k whatsoever then you get the
same lower bound for accounting
whatsoever even reaction has to be more
Catholics yeah you need to pay attention
that's during your reduction you do not
increase the parameter but super
linearly or you can increase the
parameter super annually but then you
will not get this n to the little o of
kale or bond so for instance that there
are problems were actually the best
known algorithm runs the time n to the
square root of K and then you can get
reductions that blow up your parameter
quadratically so they give you a tight
lower bound for these problems as well
okay so this is so far the part where
introduced the framework and the
definitions that it can be used to study
problems in exponential time complexity
and parameterize complexity now I want
to actually apply this to something so
we want to now turn to this problem of
counting perfect matchings and graphs
that have a simpler structure and in
particular we will also like we want to
consider this under the lens of
parameterize complexity and also under
exponential time complexity so okay
counting perfect matchings in graphs
that have some simple structure so we
know already that perfect matchings a
Sharpie hard to come sharpie hard to
count even on bipartite graphs so if x
pro titans where a restriction that you
would consider simpler than this is bad
news and i also mentioned earlier that
even if your maximum degree is 3 then
the problem is a sharpie hard but there
are structural restrictions of graphs
that make counting perfect matchings
easy and well probably the most famous
one is that of planar graphs so if you
have a planar graph you can count
perfect matchings in polynomial time and
this was extended later to two other
settings as well so for instance there
is a 4 to the K times n cube algorithm
for counting perfect matchings in graphs
that have some genus k and here i assume
that you're given a drawing of your
graph on that surface of GSK as well and
we can now say that this running time
here is FP t NK assuming that you're
given the drawing but another way of
relaxing this planarity might be to just
take a planar graph to which you added k
additional apx vertices so this means
that you have some planar base graph and
K vertices that can connect arbitrarily
to the base graph if you delete these
apex vertices you would end up with that
planar graph you can see that counting
perfect matchings in these graphs can be
done in time n to the K plus let's say
three because you can just use brute
force and the FK
method together so for each of these
apc's you just guess it's matching
partner in the base graph this gives you
n to the K choices and then once you
guessed the matching partner you can
delete the apex and its partner and you
end up with the planar graph in which
you count perfect matchings and put
another time so all together you get you
get this running time and yeah this
running time of course smells up w one
heart and one of the goals of the
remainder of the stock would be to prove
that it is actually shop w one heart so
i can always put a graph on a surface is
there some people know like how i can
make the genius small fish the number of
vertices so there are graphs that have
quadratic Geno's and and if this is what
you're asking I guess so this first
thing sharpie marker bipartite graphs
plus yeah plus that it's a four fixed
genius it's polynomial time and it kind
of means that like I expect part
bipartite graphs can only be embedded
services genius it grows yeah I mean
from this you can you could know for
instance conclude that assuming that p
is not equal sharpie there must be
graphs that have at least genus Logan
yeah other more direct ways of proving
heads but but yeah for sure yeah so so
this works only if your jeans are small
and generally graphs might have a genius
that grows linear an end or even
quadratically in n so then you would
actually be better off by just
brute-forcing over over the perfect
matchings rather than applying this
algorithm but let's say if you have a
graph that can be embedded on a torus
then that's awesome when you get to the
poly time everything okay so yeah before
showing this actually I just want to
give a overview over other parameters
that we also have in this area for
counting perfect matchings that are that
are also interesting and give
interesting results so I mentioned
earlier of course the genus of the
minimum genius of a surface on which you
control G the apex number which will
just be the minimum size of a set such
that the elite deleting that set gives
you a planar graph then there is a there
is a graph parameter and parameters
complexity that is extremely popular
which is the tree with and essentially
this measures how close your graph is to
a tree so three sub tree with one but
clicks a clip with a tree with n minus 1
and for instance grids have like an a
cape times K grid has a tree with of K
but unfortunately I cannot give you a
formal definition because the formal
definition is quite unintuitive let me
just say that it matters how close your
office to a tree
yep is that poor to the K the number set
like a chopper 1 Z 2 coefficients of the
searches if it's it's the maximum genus
off Europe know that number 4 to the k
is the number of spin structures is that
is that like that for if you can you can
take so a surface of genus k would be
one which is a sphere to which you had
attached k handles and k cross cups I'm
saying this number for the k is the
number of spin structures on a surface
of GSK is that why that appears in that
complexity I don't know I think about
I'm caste lines algorithm and I should
just do that but for every spin
structure I don't know to be honest
and I assume spin structure fire
something appealing statistical physics
or also in topology you have a fax
number because I have to really commit
sexual to the no matter and our setting
it will actually not matter you just get
an additional F of K in the running time
if it were not an independent set
okay so additional and okay additionally
the graph parameters that are
interesting in the setting are the
support hardware number so the hard work
number of a graph is the maximum k such
that g has AK clique minor so for
instance planar graphs have hard work at
number four because they exclude k 33 n
k5 as a minor and then we can also
modify this notion of the applicant
number to something called the single
crossing minor number that would just be
the minimum size of an excluded single
crossing minor so single crossing minor
is just the minor that you can draw on
the plane with at most one crossing and
for instance k 33 and k 5 have these
properties that you can draw them with
at most one crossing and then there are
some some interesting relations between
these parameters so for instance the
single crossing minor number and well if
this number is bounded and of course you
had with a number responded because
excluding a single crossing minor means
that you exclude some click and i
mentioned earlier the planar graphs
exclude fixed minors the same applies
also to browse that that have a bounded
genus so for each for each graph for the
class of graphs it can be embedded on a
surface of a given gino's there is a
finite set of minors that is excluded in
a particular there is a clique that is
excluded and you can see that something
similar also holds if the epics number
is bounded so then again the hardware
number will be bounded and if you tree
with a spawn it then in fact you're
single crossing mine are not responded
because um if you if you have a boundary
but then you actually excluded grid and
this is even a planar graph so in
particular it's good a single crossing
graph there are also other parameters
but I will not mention those too much in
the remainder of the talk so what we're
going to do now is just take these
parameters and for each of them like
state whether it's a PTO shaft everyone
heart and try to prove some of these
results also so for instance for the
genus I mentioned
that's you you get an F fitty running
time but we can show that assuming
Sharpie th you cannot get a running time
the distaff exponentially on the gyms so
2 to the little of gina's would not be
in there FX number can be solved in time
n to the K plus some constant but it
cannot be solved in time n to the little
of K over log K assuming Sharpie th so
this is not exactly tight so there is an
upper bound which is n to the K but only
a lower bound that is k / la que it
would be somewhat interesting to get rid
of this lock but we don't know yet how
to do that considering tree with the
problem is also fpt so you can get an
algorithm that runs in time in 2 to the
3 with and you can get a lower bound
that laps like sub exponentially in the
tree with is also not possible then
considering the single crossing minor
number the problem is also fpt so there
is some function which is unfortunately
too ugly to write down times n to the 4
which which you get for counting graphs
excluding some single crossing minor and
then finally of course the question is
for the heart wigan number which would
be kind of the most interesting or like
the most general parameter in the
setting and actually for for quite some
wide was even an open question whether
we can solve the problem in polynomial
time for graphs of big star Twitter
number and it turned out a few weeks ago
that the program is actually Sharpie
hearts even if you're Hardwick a number
is fixed so kind of this most general
parameter unfortunately becomes kind of
interesting in the setting of parameters
complexity because here you are already
hard for a fixed choice of the parameter
okay so in the remainder of the talk I
try to prove these two things so the sub
exponential lower bound for the genus
and this load bound for the apex number
and the general proof outline that I'll
be using is well we will use holand
problems to kind of get some
intermediate problem from which you can
reduce some hard memorized problem and
then from the whole length problem we
reduced to counting perfect matchings so
we'd start with something that is hard
as a parameter s problem we were given
some sharp a and an instance X with
parameter K we will map this to a whole
and problem on a signature of Omega that
we also have a parameter bound by K
prime but like the parameters ation of
the solent problem is not necessarily
that of a shar-pei and then we use this
whole in problem to counting perfect
matchings firstly in a weighted graph
and we ensure that the parameter during
this reduction will not increase too
much so an a weighted problem of
counting perfect matchings here will
just be given an edge weighted graph sum
over the perfect matchings and for each
perfect matching take the product of the
edge weights appearing in it and then in
a final step we can use this weighted
problem to an unweighted problem but I
will completely skip this last step in
this talk so we'll just be proceeding
along this longest line and one first
example of this proof technique or where
this notation of framework more more to
say and would be we start with the
problem of counting satisfying
assignments to 3c NFS and we will use
this accounting perfect matchings so in
other words we we prove that we we prove
the the Sharpie hardness of weighted
counting of perfect matchings and then
like an additional feature of our
reduction that we will pay attention to
is that if we have n variables and M
clauses we end up with a graph that has
only off n plus n vertices in here so
since having a sub exponential time
algorithm for three sets would refute
eh this reduction chamber tell us that
to to the little o of tea time algorithm
for counting perfect matchings would
refute Sharpie THS way and again this is
like so this is nothing new this is a
this is a known result and we just we
prove it in a in a let's say in a
streamlined way and then using this
first example of proofs by hollins in a
simple setting we can then adapt this to
more complex proofs later so let's start
and we just record briefly what a whole
and problem is in in the setting that
that we were using here so we start with
a signature graph Omega that would be an
instance to a hole in problem which is
just a graph G and at each vertex we
have a signature attached so this is
some FV which maps from edge assignments
like assignments to the edges incident
with be and here we consider binary
assignments to some complex number so
for instance this vertex year could have
some signature which ranges over the
fore edge assignments and just assign
some complex numbers to it and then the
quantity that we're interested in is
this whole end of Omega so we just sum
over all the edge assignments to to the
signature graph binary edge assignments
we take the product over all vertices
and for each vertex we just evaluate
this assignment X on the edges incident
with v then of course one one of the
best examples for a hole in problem or
one of the first examples would be well
if you attach all the if you attach the
perfect matching signature to all
vertices of your signature graph and
then you can count perfect matchings
violence so this is just the signature
that gives one if your edge assignment
why has unique one in other words it
will give zero then you can check easily
that the whole end of Omega would just
be equal to the number of perfect
matchings angie and this perfect
matching signature would be very
important in this remainder of the top
so just just looks at the incidents
address and if there's exactly one in
there that that is active and it gives a
one so we can express counting perfect
matchings as a whole and problem but of
course is the frame of a so general that
we can express pretty much anything that
is defined locally so in particular we
can express a three-set as a whole new
problem so we just if we have n
variables then we just create and very
good vertices 4m plus we create and
claws vertices we connect variables to
clauses and then if a variable has a
greedy we attach this equality signature
to it which will just enforce equality
equality on all the edges incident with
that with that variable vertex and four
clauses we just attach a signature that
is literally the clause function as a
boolean function and then you can check
that the number of satisfying
assignments of Phi will just be the hole
in the floor mega because the qualities
in each you're interested you that all
the satisfying assignments to this whole
end will be actually variable
assignments to the n variables and then
the cloth signatures just check whether
all the other clauses are satisfied but
of course what we want to do is we want
to be able to reduce this to counting
perfect matchings so to get this last
step here and to do this we we use magic
gates and like here's a little twist so
when I talk about match gates in this
talk I always mean non-planar educates
so match gates that are not necessarily
planar and because it turns out that
these are quite useful for such
reductions so what is a magic eight and
that would be a magic eight gamma it's
just a signature graph itself which has
some address with edge weights and some
of these edges are dangling which means
that they have only one that they have
only one
endpoint and they're essentially want to
have some external partner there and all
the vertices appearing in gamma only
have the perfect matching signature
attached to it so then we can define a
signature for a match gate so the
signature of a Magic eight is just it
ranges over edge assignments to the
dangling edges and maps into complex
numbers and for a given fixed assignment
to the dangling address that would just
be essentially a whole and restricted to
assignments that extend this fixed
assignment yeah and then the useful
things about the useful thing about
nachiket is that if you have a signature
graph Omega and each vertex has a
signature FD and for each week we
additionally have a magic eight gamma V
such that the signature of that magic
eight agrees with FV then we can just
insert these and educates and get a new
signature of Omega prime here is the
example of an insertion and we can check
easily like we can check elementally
that the whole end of Omega will be
equal to that of Omega Prime and if we
do this for all the vertices in the
original signature graph then we end up
with a signature graph that has only the
perfect matching signature attached so
in particular this is just a number of
perfect matchings of some graph and of
course this works only if we actually
have the match gates for the signature
said we're interested in but it turns
out that if we drop this restriction of
linearity which is extremely useful in
let's say reductions to the fkd method
and if we just drop this planarity then
it turns out that we actually can get
non planar match gates for all
signatures so whenever you have a
signature F of some Ltd which can be
realized by some magic eight Gunnar then
we can check easily that F must satisfy
certain parity condition so either the
signature is even or it's odd meaning
that either on all the axis of odd or
even hemingway's its value zero and so
if
the magic eight signature this parity
condition must be satisfied but
conversely we can show that if if a
signature has at most s nonzero entries
and it satisfies the parity condition
then we actually get a match gate with
edge weights that is of size all of s
times D so in particular this means that
if you're looking at signatures that
have some constant arity then you can
get constant size match gates for
realizing these signatures which are not
necessarily planar and yeah now we can
just use this to to finally reduce the
solent problem that in called SAT to
counting perfect matchings so there is a
small a small caveat that that needs to
be taken care of it might be that the
signatures that we have in here violate
this parity condition but we can get
around this very easily by just doubling
the edges so there is a simple hack we
just for each clause we just take the
literals in there copy them and we add
parallel edges so this will ensure that
that the edges that were previously in
there now appears pairs and this
equality signature here ensures that
these pairs always have the same value
so this means in particular that the
loss signature is now an even signature
yeah so also it increases also it
actually doubles the degree of each
variable which means that we can now
actually realize this equality signature
because equality signatures of odd
parity cannot be realized by magic aids
no sorry an equality signature of odd
parity is neither even nor odd as a
signature okay so now we can invoke this
this theorem that we have natural gas
for everything and reduce accounting
perfect matchings in a weighted graph so
we just take match gates here which have
constant size because the cloth
signature has constant arity and here we
get match guys that have off d size but
the sum of the degrees must be m and MS
o of n so in totally we get a reduction
to counting perfect matching some growth
with
android disease okay so this would be
kind of the most simple the most simple
way of utilizing the soul and framework
or so to say abusing the whole in
framework for forgetting and forgetting
proofs in exponential time complexity
for instance but we can generally prove
a lot of things this way so for instance
this lower bound for the genus that I
promised earlier stating that you cannot
count perfect matchings in time to to
the little of genius it can be also
proven in that way so again we start
from a formula Phi which has n variables
and M clauses now we reduce to a to a
more carefully designed Signature graph
Omega so previously we just took this
variable clause incidents graph now we
actually put some more effort into this
part of the reduction so we construct a
planar graph and actually this one down
here and this graph will have n times n
vertices so it's essentially in n times
n grids where you have paths for each
variable and columns elective rose for
each variable and columns for each
clause and you can ensure that in this
graph here each vertex has degree at
most 10 so you can see here that this
graph here is well okay it should be six
actually but yeah so anyway the the
degree of this graph is bounded and in
this signature graph we will have
signatures that can be realized by
planar match gates and signatures that
can be realized by non planar educates
but it turns out that we can tweak our
reduction in such a way that there are
only off and many non planar signatures
so essentially to realize a clause we
will need three types of signatures like
one so to say passive signature which is
just supposed to to transfer an
assignment from down to bottom without
changing at the door and then a positive
literal signature at the negative
literal signature which is for literal
said actually appear in our clothes but
there are only linearly many because
we're reducing from vfc
so generally the idea is that we we have
an assignment to the variable x1 which
is propagated along this row so all the
edges in this row have the assignments
to x1 and this of course applies to all
the variables and then these roles sorry
these columns check whether applause is
satisfied so essentially we proceed from
top to bottom and we check whether the
clause has been satisfied by the seminar
we've read so far okay and now finally
we can use this to reduce the solent
problem to counting perfect matchings in
a weighted graph which has only linearly
many crossings why that so here we have
a planar graph and into this graph we
will insert only off and match gates
which are non planar and these meds are
all constant so that means we insert all
of n match gates that have crossings but
there can be only off one crossings in
each match gate because it has constant
size so in the end we we end up with a
with a graph that has only linearly many
crossings and therefore i partake in
particular it has only genus o of n so
if you could if you could if you could
now solve counting perfect matchings
here faster likes up exponentially then
you would also count three set sub
exponentially so this is a one way of
proving lower bounds using holland's but
there is another another approach that I
want to sketch now and the remaining few
minutes and that would be proving things
by a so-called combined signatures so
using this technique of combined
signatures mingjie and I were able to
prove a lower bound for the apex number
so we get this end to the little of
cable okay and so far the proof outlined
that I mentioned was that we start with
some parameterize problem with a
parameter K and we're used to the
homeland on a signature graph Omega with
parameter K Prime and we end up at
counting perfect matchings with
parameter
prime prime now in this framework of
combined signatures what we'll be doing
is we actually don't do this direct
route but we first reduce this whole and
problem to some number of F of K Prime
instances to other opponent problems
which again have bounded parameter and
then each of these Hollen problems will
reduce the planar graph and typically
the this number of instances that we get
here is let's say an exponential in K
Prime and the parameter is bound by some
function of K so this means that in
total we get some number of instances
for this other holon problem here which
the number of instances will be bounded
by some function in K so this will be a
valid fpt reduction because the only
thing that we require an FPT reductions
is that the running time is FP t hear
these things actually gave us polynomial
time reductions and let me just sketch
know how these combined signatures work
so the idea is that in combined
signatures in this framework of combined
signatures we have a signature graph
Omega that has some set of special
vertices so we have a set X consisting
of K vertices which are special in some
way at all non special vertices we have
the perfect matching signature so these
sorties are taken care of by means of
match gates and at the special vertices
like at VI we have a special signature
Fi and special in this setting would
mean something like maybe we can't
realize it by plane imagicate so we
cannot realize it by the types of match
gates that we are interested in but you
can realize it as a linear combination
of other signatures so for each I we
have to match gate signatures GI one and
GL to such that F is just the sum of GI
one and GI two and in fact you can allow
arbitrary linear combinations at least
at this point but just to simplify
notation just
I'm your son and so f I might not be
expressible itself by magic eight but
these two but these two signatures can
be and these signatures could not be
realized by something but actually some
easy match case for instance they could
both be planar and then this might be
interesting because there is a very
simple observation that we can
essentially express the homeland of
Omega itself then as a linear
combination of other Holland's where
each way each of these other homeland's
is just taken by replacing the special
signature by some choice of these magic
eight signatures so more formally let's
say we take the K tablets PI over 12 to
the k then for each such type of pie
define a graph Omega PI by replacing for
each I just this special signature fi by
the magic eight signature GI pie I then
it turns out that the whole end of Omega
is just the sum over their holdings of
Omega PI this is a very simple
observation but can be used now to do
stuff like this so you can now reduce
these holding problems to accounting
perfect matchings after inserting match
gates in particular we might now have
magic eights that I have a very nice
structure that we can use in our
reductions so an example for this let me
just State this very briefly would be
this reduction for the apex number so in
this setting we start from a problem
which is called counting great tilings
on parameter K which actually has this
lower bound that you were aiming for and
to reduce this problem of counting great
tilings which I cannot define formally
unfortunately here and to a Holland
problem on a planar graph so a signature
graph like this one here which has only
off case special vertices
then finally we realized the signature
of these special vertices by the linear
combination of two match gates which
look like this so the first met Kate is
actually planar itself and the second
match gate is almost planar but it has
these two apex of vertices which somehow
connect two vertices in there and then
using this combined signature linear
combination statement from the last
slide we can reduce this whole end to to
to the o FK instances of Holland of
Omega Prime we're here now we have only
the signature of these match gates
appearing and in particular this allows
us to reduce from here to counting
perfect matchings and graphs that have
only off ka pcs because when we have at
most K special vertices we have 0 of K
special vertices and disappear in a
planar graph and the worst thing that
can happen is that you realize all these
special vertices in this linear
combination by this to apex match gate
but this would mean that you get a graph
that has two times of ka pcs which is
fine so altogether that gives us a
reduction from this counting great
tilings problem to an exponential number
NK of graphs that have only off ka pcs
and then this allows us to transfer this
lower bound here to that lower bound
there ok and that actually concludes my
talk so let me just recap briefly what
was going on we had a we had these
simple things which were constrained the
ends and which in the end translated to
counting perfect matchings involves with
some simply structure this was the
second half of the talk then we had
little things which was the setting of
counting small sub graphs and there was
this dichotomy theorem for that and then
slow things were tight lower bounds
assuming this exponential hypothesis
there of course a lot of interesting
open problems in this area let me just
maybe stay three of them so the first
one might be what about this problem of
context
graphs if your pattern has maximum
degree 3 so can you do that in n time n
to the o of K n to the little of k and
the best-known bounce that that are
known are actually again of this type
that you have n to the K over log K so
it would be nice to get rid of this log
K in the lower bound or actually improve
the algorithm but it's not really known
how to do that you know you're this year
algorithm for that though no so get a
decision algorithm or improve the lower
bound for the counting version it's a
super might be this would be a simpler
reepham a simpler statement and what
would also be interesting like exactly
the same question can also be asked
about counting perfect matchings on k
epics graphs and in fact if you if you
manage to get a n to the o FK algorithm
here then you would essentially also get
the same running time here that is not
entirely true but it's more really true
but these two things are I would say
wide open so far what would be more
feasible right now is we're taking some
of these extensive and sweeping
dichotomy theorem stead are known for
CSP or Holland problems and extending
them to a setting where you don't get
just polynomial time there's a Sharpie
completeness but polynomial time versus
some tight lower bound under Sharpie th
and maybe this is something that we
could tackle with whoever is interested
over the course of the semester and yeah
thanks for your attention
may be coming back to the first question
from there before the talk oh yeah that
was just on Photoshop
so when you say number 88 hard I guess
you mean can't be done in time to to the
BLA less number 80 ages walls or
something yeah
very simple setting population of the
here is this issue of choosing
parameters and what kind of promises you
allow this seems to be pretty so is
there some
just one single
there's something between so something
that I was maybe considering interesting
would be just by parameterize actually
just by the number of vertices or the
number of variables in your instance so
for instance you could consider Holland
parametrized by just the number of
vertices appearing in your signature
graph and then then it would be still
interesting to get char pth lower bounds
because for instance getting a lower
bound for counting perfect matchings
would fit into this framework for
instance and I would say that this is an
interesting without under Sharpie th but
more generally you could ask for what
happens if we if you place arbitrary
signatures maybe maybe of bounded you
have bounded arity first to have some
something to start with we do we
actually get some problems which are sub
exponential time solvable by picking
other other signatures than the perfect
matching signature I would suspect that
the answer is no unless you get you get
signatures that are so easy that it's
even polynomial-time solvable but I
don't really know so I don't even know
whether we actually have all the
techniques needed to do that so for
instance for quite some while it was it
was even not known how to really do
interpolation in the setting of e th but
due to some recent papers we can
actually do this now so we can actually
now do a tight way of interpolation
under ETH so for instance previously
like I mentioned this lower bound for
counting perfect matchings on edge
weighted graphs getting rid of these
weights previously incurred a log n
factor so you could only get segments
like to to the little off n over log n
which refutes RP th but now actually we
can do this title
can be the truest founder of Denmark's
raise to n to the K how much we
landscape then all of these actually
most of the lock case will disappear and
like one way of raising this can you be
tree with lower bound would be to
actually consider the counting version
of that because there we have additional
freedom and it might be easier to prove
hardness in the counting centre the
other direction helmet how how about the
other direction of the implicit we have
these lower bound into the cake we have
yeah yeah so if you if you if you had
any of these little ofk things here then
you would get you would be tree with
the equivalent somehow is
um
where where can you be three with
implies raising this wood okay raising
that can you be three with bound would
imply tight lower balance here so in
other words breaking breaking these
things would break 3 with so to say
it's a reduction and the other way
around and I'm not quite sure
the speaker